too destructive for his own
regime, so far.
>> Ivan Watson in Hong Kong,
thanks so much.
Joining us now for a bipartisan
interview the top members of
the house select committee on
the competition between China
and the U.S. Mike Gallagher and
we thank you both for doing
this.
It certainly says a lot that
you are appearing in a
bipartisan way.
Chairman Gallagher, you have
said that unity he is the
greatest strength against
China.
How are you and your fellow
committee members going to keep
tonight's hearing going for are
ward and not partisan politics?
>> The good news is we have
worked productive together on a
variety of ires 6th issues.
We recognize we don't have to
have agree on having but when
it comes to the threat we face
from Chinese communist party I
think we see it clearly, and we
want to identify that
bipartisan center of gravity
where we can push back against
transnational repression from
the ccp.
I'm cautious 8 optimistic if
for no other reason than the
list of members we have on both
sides.
Speaker Mccarthy appointed very
serious, sober members, not
bomb throwers.
Member Jefferies appointed some
talented Democrats that I have
worked with.
>> China's fraying ties with
the west have been on full
display recently.
Obviously the China spy balloon
incidents, U.S. Warnings that
China is considering arming
Putin's army, the escalating
standoffs about Taiwan, the
Chinese communist party
possibly spying here in the
United States, competition over
semi conductor manufacturing,
not to mention renewed
questions over covid's origins.
That's just some of the issues
here.
What's first on your agenda,
and why?
>> You're absolutely right,
there's so many issues.
And if you talk to Mike or my
constituents, a lot of them
have their own concerns about
each of those issues.
One of issues that we're
probably going to talk about
tonight is the economic issues
and the trade issues that have
ended up hollowing out the
manufacturing sectors in the
heartland, whether it's
Wisconsin or Illinois or other
places, because of unfair trade
practices, because of
industrial espionage, because
of forced technology transfer
that many of our small and
other businesses must engage
in, in order to do business in
the people's republic of China.
So I think that's going to be
top of mind as well.
>> Congressman Gallagher,
chairman Gallagher, one of the
big issues, and I don't know
how the United States can
address it, is that there are
so many dollars in China that
organizations like the NBA and
the film industry, they don't
seem to care about the cultural
genocide of wiegers or Taiwan.
They just want those dollars.
>> It's the same reason why
John dillinger robbed banks.
That's where the money.
I think we have to not only
appeal to patriotism but start
to put in place guardrails that
at a minimum make sure that we,
I.e.
U.S. Taxpayers, citizen, aren't
unwittingly funding communist
genocide because we're allowing
for technology transfer or
American capital to invest in
Chinese defense companies.
Where this gets very
complicated, there's a concept
in China of civil military
fusion.
At times it's very difficult to
identify the opaque lines
between a shipping company in
China and the pla Navy.
I would submit the concept of a
private Coyne China is tenuous
at best and may not even exist.
You believe we can put in place
a framework for sensitive
economic de-coupling.
>> That issue you just talked
about, whether or not there can
even be a private company in
China, the fact that it's an
oppressive Chinese government,
that comes into play when it
comes to tiktok.
Congressman, you said you do
not think there will be an
outright ban on tiktok in the
United States this year but
yesterday the government direct
all federal agencies to ban
tiktok on all federal he
devices within the next month.
Clearly the U.S. Government
doesn't want it on its devices.
Canada is taking steps to get
rid of it.
Why not ash ban on tiktok for
every device in the U.S.?
>> I think that what we're
saying is we don't want it to
be turned the control of an
adversarial regime.
If there was a forced sale of
tiktok usa to some other
company, for instance, an
American company, I think that
people would be much more
comfortable, because at the end
of the day, folks are obviously
already exercised about social
media, certainly in my
household we're not super happy
about this.
But have to have user data and
then algorithms and content
ultimately controlled by the
Chinese communist party is a
bridge too far.
I think that is the issue that
we have to confront with regard
to tiktok and byte dance.
>> Chairman Gallagher, you have
talked about de coupling
China's economy with the U.S.
Economy.
How does that even work?
What does that look like in
practice?
We get so many goods from
China.
And we sell so much incident
electric you the wall property
and product to China as well.
>> I think it's critical to
say, at least I'm not
advocating for a complete de-
coupling.
I don't have a problem selling
soybeans to China.
But when it comes to key
technology, or critical goods,
think advanced pharmaceutical
ingredients, we don't want to
be dependent on the largess of
the China's economy he when it
comes to life saving drug.
We've got to find a way to near
should, on shore, friend-shore,
whatever the term is we are
using.
When it comes to weapon systems
I think we can take some steps
to reclaim our economic
Independence.
I want to make sure that major
asset managers and university
endowments as well as state and
local pension funds aren't
subsidizing general no side in
China or pla modernization.
>> I read a piece in, I think
politico, criticizing Democrats
in general, certainly not you
specifically.
Former speaker Pelosi has been
hawkish on China for decades
but generally your party has
not been out there in the
house.
Why not?
>> Well, I think that it's a
nuanced conversation, or it
should be, because we want to
make sure that at the same time
that we make our differences
known with the Chinese
communist party that we set
aside the people of China, our
people of Chinese origin or
ages Americans, because we
don't want to in any way
encourage the stereotyping or
discrimination or tropism that
often infect our conversations
with regards to the people's
republic of China.
Certainly in the last four
years, let's say, there's been
a rise of hate crimes towards
Asian Americans, and we don't
want to contribute to that.
So it's very clear that on this
committee, I think Mike and I
agree, our quarterly is not
with the people of China or
Chinese origin people.
We need to stand up to the
threats or challenges posed by
the Chinese communist party.
>> Yeah.
And nobody is more a victim of
the Chinese communist party